[Music]
chris we've got a question from a
youtuber randall says uh
this is the first year i'm in a position
to give generously
what do i need to consider when it comes
to giving to an organization i've heard
about a maximum
for a gift tax does that apply to all
giving
yeah well first of all first and
foremost randall congratulations on
putting yourself in a position to be
able to be a blessing
because giving is a two-way blessing it
blesses the the place that you're giving
to the cause you're supporting
but it also gives you a blessing and so
it is without a shadow of a doubt the
most fun you can have with money
yeah it is and you're gonna you know we
always teach us three things to do with
money
uh you need to enjoy it meaning
lifestyle most people don't struggle
with that one
you need to give it and you need to save
and invest it so that you can do more
of the giving and the enjoying that's
right but you will find the further you
get in your financial journey the
further down into your everyday
millionaire journey that you get
that the more joy that you do get more
joy from
properly done giving now improperly done
giving would be
giving to something that's distant and
you have no emotional connection to
you don't get the the givers high but if
you you know you got a single mom
sitting next to it to you in church
and you reach over and pay her rent for
half a year because she lost her job for
covid
that's a giving that connects blesses
her blesses you that kind of a thing
now the gift tax only applies if you're
not giving
to a non-profit now a non-profit would
be your church a ministry something in
the area that's a 501c3
okay and so if it's not a if it's a
501c3 there's no limit on how much you
can give
there's a limit on how much you can take
as a tax deduction depending on your
income and your accountant can help you
with that formula
but the 501c3 is 100
deductible if you're giving to an
individual
like you're just going to give your
brother some money or something like
that then you do have a fifteen thousand
dollar
gift tax limitation this year and you
wanna be really careful with going over
that there's some techniques you can use
to go over that
if you want to give to individuals but
if you go over that and don't use some
kind of a technique
everything over that's going to be taxed
upward of 50 percent
so the gift tax is horrendous do not
do not give away a hundred thousand
dollars just act like to your to your
mother-in-law and just act like that's
okay you're gonna wish you had never met
your mother-in-law when the tax bill
comes
so uh you know you gotta do that so
here's one technique
if you're married and you're gonna give
some money to your kids
who are married your son and
daughter-in-law okay
then you can give him 15 and her 15.
your wife can give him 15 in her 15.
now we got four fifteen thousand dollar
checks or sixty thousand transferred
that's but i write four separate checks
and make sure you've got a real clean
paper trail that would all qualify
but if you're going to go over that over
60 in that scenario
you're going to have to figure out some
other techniques and you would check out
what's called the unified estate tax
credit
where you can get some advice from your
tax account and get this going but the
bottom line is
if you're giving to a ministry you just
don't have to worry about it and you're
through a ministry or something like
that
there's a lot of ways to do this and
congratulations on joining the big boy
club the big girl club because when you
start giving that's when you're
officially an adult
dave i've never heard you use the term
the giving high
but there is something about that i tell
you when you step into a situation
anonymously or or regardless uh
it does do something to your spirit it
really does it it it increases
everything you're just excited well i'm
getting old and i've got a lot of famous
friends now
and one of them is named santa claus and
there's a reason santa claus is jolly
yeah he gets to give to kids all the
time yeah
and he's you know he's always laughing
you know he's always grinning
and you know you never see people that
are generous people
with a scowl that's not a generous
person
they don't give money you know think
about the if you think of the face of a
miser
scrooge scrooge yeah you think of a
scowl
yeah but when you think of somebody
giving you see you immediately see this
great
big smile with all those teeth sticking
out
and because that's that's a giving a
generous person
you can see it on their countenance you
can see it on their face
you can see it in the way they walk when
you start to give
i'm so excited for you randall because
you're going to discover a whole new
segment of life
when you become outrageously and crazy
generous
uh because when you start to do this it
affects your personality
and here's the thing generous people are
highly attractive
these are attractive individuals you're
going to find out you get promotions at
work
you're going to find out that people
want to hire you for projects
you're going to be asked to join the
club that you never thought you know
because all of a sudden you're just a
likable dude
you know because it's not because they
want your money no no it's something
about you internally
you because generosity is not an act
it's a character quality
integrity is not an act it's a character
quality
and what you're doing here is you're
developing this character quality
with the act of physical literal
monetary generosity it really is and i
want to remind everybody giving is not
just about money you've got an
opportunity to be able to give with your
time as well as your talent
and so that giving aspect is money time
talent look for opportunities or causes
that you believe in and engage with them
uh it is amazing what happens and i
think that's one of the ways we can heal
this nation
is to get our mindset shifted on being
able to give back and engage with people
yeah it's um that there is something
that happens in the human spirit when
you do this
so you know if you're going to do over
15 000 you need to investigate the tax
issues
and if you're going to be giving to a
ministry or a non-profit if you're
giving the red cross that's a non-profit
for hurricane relief if you're giving to
uh
the homeless shelter it's usually going
to be a non-profit in your city
okay or if you're giving to a ministry
that's an extension of your church and
you're giving to a missionary family
through the church
that kind of a thing or giving to a
missionary project where a house is
being built in a
in a uh in a developing country or
something for a family or they're
building a schoolhouse you're you know
you're directing it through there that's
all 100 deductible you don't have to
worry about it
i remember you saying talking years ago
when i first started you said you know
you get all kinds of people coming at
you
uh all kinds of charities and things of
that nature but you said you and sharon
will sit down
and talk about what causes you're going
to support
and you make a list of those and and you
you lavishly support
that list and i i really like that
because you're being
as intentional with your giving as you
are with your budgeting yeah and then
when someone's mad because i say no
that's okay right i'm okay with that
yeah because it's not your
money you don't get to decide
you don't have a vote today we don't do
it with sharon and i today we do it
through the ramsey family foundation
that my daughter runs
right and so actually i just got an
email a few minutes ago she's setting up
the annual meeting
where we will go through and establish
the list this year
and uh and it's not a thing where you're
from the outside you can
you know do a grant entry to the ramsey
family foundation
it's just our methodology of pooling the
cash and then
100 of the ministries and things that we
choose are something that we somehow
one of us ramsey kids ramsey in-law kids
me sharon are connected to and sometimes
it's something we've met this year
right but sometimes it's one we've
supported for 25 years
you know and we just have continued to
do that so again it's a small list
but then that way we're able to keep the
gifts where they're meaningful
yeah uh in other words we're not doing
500
gifts of 500 that would drive you
bananas at tax time
you know plus you get everybody coming
at you then yeah
and you know you're like because once
you do that once
it's like that guy's over there that
guy's over there that guy's over there
that guy's over there and all of a
sudden you're on six
you know six charity boards and and
you're on the board just because they
want your money and all that kind of
stuff so
you get you get off into the dark side
of this thing really quickly if you're
not careful
so keep it to where it's manageable
where you enjoy
it and go ahead and vet the organization
if you're going to give them a lot what
you call a lot of money then spend a lot
of time
on it go hey this co this place you know
like i'll tell you an example
if they borrow money well we can't give
to them
in our case because that would be a
guideline if you're a ramsey duh
we don't borrow money so why am i going
to give money to them so they can give
money the bank
that would be dumb right be inconsistent
with who i am as a person right or our
family is his people so
that would be an example at our house
maybe maybe you got something at your
house that you say
you know if they do x or do why we're
not gonna do this so you need to
investigate make sure they're running
the thing well
make sure it's managed well make sure
the operating principles are right
so hey roland randall i'm proud of you
man
uh you just you're entering a whole
another phase hold another gear baby
brother go you're gonna have fun
generosity is the best part of the whole
money picture
this is the dave ramsey show